well newly released video of the deadly
shooting of a black man by a white
police officer in Tennessee is spurring
calls for the officer to be charged with
murder prosecutors released the
surveillance footage yesterday it
appears to show Nashville police officer
Andrew Del key chasing Daniel Hamrick
last month before opening fire Hamrick
was hit three times mark Strassmann is
in Nashville with reaction to the new
video mark good morning good morning
this is the street where the fatal
shooting happened that now has Nationals
mayor calling for a complete review of
the police department these flowers
marked the spot where Daniel Hamrick
fell fatally wounded the police union
says there's a lot more to this story
than what the surveillance tape shows
but hammers family is demanding more
answers I just want justice for my son
and my family
Victoria Hamrick supported by her family
and attorney believes videos showing the
shooting of her son Daniel Hamm Brooke
on July 26th is proof that police deadly
force was not justified the police
officer chases him with his guns wrong
and at some point he slows down and
executes sir police say officer dulky
was searching for a stolen car when he
ran into Hamrick the video appears to
show hambric running from the officer
before he was shot in the back and head
police later tweeted a picture of a gun
they say Hambrick was carrying and
refused to drop the Nashville Fraternal
Order of Police argues Hambrick could
have shot the officer at any moment it
is our firm belief that Officer Delfy
acted reasonably under the totality of
the circumstances Nashville Mayor David
Briley called for calm while the
investigation continued getting it to
the bottom of this is very important
it's equally important that while we
past time waiting for the investigation
to be complete that we be patient but
the Hamburg family believes this is an
open-and-shut case no way and we do want
justice served for him officer del key
has been placed on administrative leave
he wasn't wearing a body camera and his
cruiser did not have a dashboard camera
vlad we reached out to national police
for comment about officer del key and
haven't heard back all right mark thank
you very much